uh i just want to say thank you i i love
your work and i really just want to
thank you for
for everything you've done um it's just
really brought me a lot of uh you know
i've just really enjoyed watching you
work so thank you thank you
um so i like throwing a curveball at the
beginning um if someone has actually
never seen
anything that you've done um before what
would be the first thing you want them
watching and why
wow
i guess i'd say the tragedy of macbeth
because
maybe that's my most
mature work
i don't know if that's the reason why
but
i i feel comfortable about my work
where i am with my work now so i would
say i would say tragedy even better
um you the last time you did shakespeare
on film was in 1993 with uh which it was
much ado about nothing have you been
approached about doing something else
shakespeare since then and had you been
like sort of turning it down or was this
you know what i mean like how how did
this i guess had you been approached for
something else prior to this well i did
julius caesar i played brutus on
broadway yes not for film but but so but
no i've been asked nobody nobody called
that's crazy so um obviously you're very
talented director uh but working with
joel cohen i would imagine maybe you're
gleaning a little bit of what he's doing
to maybe to steal from it to you know
for the next thing you direct and i'm
just curious what did you learn working
with joel that you want to take with you
as a director everything
i was stealing too i mean he's a master
you know so you wonder sometime but what
why why over here why'd you why i
remember asking him one time he was
setting up a shot and i wasn't in it so
i had my director's hat on because i
wasn't in that part of the scene so i
said now i notice you put the camera
down here like a lower angle is that
are you are you making a statement is
that a psychological thing or why'd you
put the camera so low he said actually i
just like the ceiling
i was like you like the ceiling he said
yeah look up
oh yeah he said yeah i like the way the
ceiling looked
i said
it was as simple as that
he said
basically what he said was it he didn't
say this word for word but what what i
got from it was
it was as simple as that now
because he had done everything else
he was prepared he had thought about it
every way it's storyboarded he thought
about every angle and then on at that
moment he said no i like this
so he had done the work
but then he was still open to
improvisation or or you know another way
of looking at it reinterpreting it
i loved bruno's work behind the camera
and at times i thought i was watching
like a german expressionistic painting
you know or a film come to life could
you sort of talk about working with
bruno and what you enjoyed about his
cinematography
i i i love watching the two of them
collaborate you know i would get there
early in the morning so i could run
lines sometimes four in the morning five
in the morning
and very rarely was i there before bruno
he was always there always working
working with his crew and he
like setting lights himself i mean he he
was about to work and
it was just that kind of a vibe you know
we were a company uh yes a company of
actors but also
actors and and filmmakers working all
working together with
with a common goal
um i mean obviously like everyone i am a
huge fan of of your work i've mentioned
this but i love talking to actors about
the way they get ready for something and
i'm just curious um if you have like a
big emotional scene on a monday or a big
dramatic scene or something that you
know is going to be challenging for you
can you sort of talk about how you're
getting ready for that performance or
you know how early on are you thinking
about it
if you don't mind sharing well you know
one thing off the top of my head is you
know
when you're shooting a scene you're
going to be shooting it all day or maybe
over the course of two days
so
it's never usually one moment
and
most of the time when an actor thinks
it's their big moment
it usually ain't they're usually about
to mess it up because they thought about
it too much and they decided what they
want to be emotional or whatever
and usually you can catch them acting
you know i i
you never know what the big moment's
going to be
it might be a small thing
um
one of the things that i i love the
aesthetic of the film the the way that
it's all shot on sound stages the black
and white can you talk about when joel
told you that the choices he was making
for the film and your initial reaction
well he he he had photographs and and
ideas up everywhere so when you went to
the production office you could see the
movie on the wall
or you you could see
where he was going or where he wanted to
go and what influenced him and he and he
was open you know he just had pictures
and drawings and stuff everywhere so
there was so much to absorb
and it it
it was fun because you you maybe the
question i had wasn't for him maybe once
i saw a drawing it was like oh let me
talk to the production designer what
they had in mind since they drew that or
the art director or just going to the
different departments and and
and and it
it was just such a great
collab collaboration you know
again joel's a master and he brings in
all these great people around him so i'm
in this building with all these people
that are really good at what they do
they're all masters so you're like okay
we're in here with the best i got to
bring my best
uh i'm curious what do you think it is
about shakespeare's words that has stood
the test of time and allowed for so many
people to take their interpretation of
the material
well going back to what i just said
about the best shakespeare is sitting
there at the end of day going yeah and
i'm better than all of you
so now you got to meet shakespeare where
he lives be you joel or denzel or
francis or whoever
you we all got to bring our game up to
meet
william shakespeare where he is
um i believe that you are producing
august wilson's uh the piano lesson and
i'm just curious if you can give a
status update on that particular project
uh going to broadway john david
washington and samuel l jackson if
there's going to be a broadway
uh we'll we'll be doing the play on
broadway and and uh we we should be
shooting pretty much to close to this
time next year
oh nice um
oh my last thing for you um what are you
getting ready what are you thinking
about doing this year in terms of acting
if you don't mind me asking they have
written the the third
the third equalizer so i'm scheduled to
do
get
that
shape and start beating some people up
again i get to beat some people up again
i am all for this this is this is
fantastic i i
this is great
no serious i
and then going and beating some people
up can't be better right i love it um
listen thank you so much for your time
and seriously thank you so much for your
work thank you thank you thank you
you